but now Labor's Shadow transport
secretary that's Louise Hague is with us
to discuss this further very good
morning to you thanks very much indeed
for joining us on Sky News breakfast if
Richard Sharp is indeed uh found to have
broken the code for public appointments
should he resign
well of course we'll have to um wait to
see the outcome and the details of the
report but if it is revealed that he has
um failed to declare the details of
these this loan Arrangement properly or
failed to be forthcoming in the process
then of course he will have to go
do you think it's right uh that BBC
chair appointments do you have a
political affiliation
and I think the uh this this whole
Affairs cast great
um a a great Cloud over the public trust
in the BBC and
um the the way that appointments are
made at the moment and it's been really
concerning to see how the government has
sat back and done very little about the
potential breaches in the process and
done nothing to help restore trust and
faith in the impartiality of the BBC my
colleague Lucy Powell has set up already
in opposition an independent panel to
look at appointments and to look at
these issues in great detail and they're
already making progress on how
appointments should be made and but we
need to see the outcome of this report
and we need to see it acted on
accordingly
um I don't think it's necessarily a
problem that people have um political
affiliation but it is obviously
important that um people have faith in
the way that appointments are made and
that people then act completely and
partially in their roles within the BBC
I mean does it does it matter uh that
Richard Sharp helped facilitate this
loan for Boris Johnson if it if it
didn't impact his his actions at the BBC
or how he carried out his job
well that's what the report I think
needs to determine um but what does
matter is if he failed to
um declare it in the proper way and
exactly that if he if it allowed him or
um persuaded him or um it then led him
to behave in a way that was improper and
that's exactly what the report we hope
will determine and that's what it then
should um it then should determine how
we act and how Richard Sharp Acts
if there's no evidence of Richard Sharp
acting in an improper way should he stay
in post
well again I just don't know what this
report is going to find um but look if
he has if he has acted improperly if he
has failed to declare the loan according
to the BBC's own guidelines and then
obviously he will have to go but I think
this this whole Saga raises wider issues
around the way that the government
has approached the BBC and the
particular Links of the Tory party with
the BBC
um I'd like to talk to you about strikes
now if I may um Louise
um asleff and the rmt unions
um have announced strike dates which
will directly impact the FA Cup Final as
well as the Eurovision Song Contest in
Liverpool are you comfortable with these
unions targeting these big public events
obviously nobody wants um these strikes
to go ahead uh least of all me I'd
really like to get to Liverpool and to
help celebrate Eurovision and I've got
tickets by the way I just want to get to
Liverpool to join the
um party so we absolutely do not want
these strikes to go ahead and I will be
doing everything I can to help avoid
them in two weeks time but the unions
have given the government full notice
um and what's important to say is that
these negotiations and these industrial
action has been going on for almost a
year now that represents an enormous
failure frankly on all side but
particularly from the government who it
feels have washed their hands
um over the last few months
um about this dispute and my
understanding is that no government
Minister has been at the talks or has
been facilitating any negotiations for
nearly four months in fact my
understanding is that no transport
Minister has even made contact with one
of the unions for several months now and
that represents
um not just a failure but um an un
um unimaginable complacency frankly from
the government in relation to these
disputes so they should be holding
urgent talks now there's no reason at
all why they couldn't facilitate talks
between the employers and the unions
today and they should be straining
everything you over the next few days to
avoid these strikes in the coming weeks
yeah but just on on the issue of
Eurovision
um it may it may seem Petty that I'm
drilling down into this but you know
there are Ukrainian refugees who are
going to Liverpool we're hosting
Eurovision on behalf of Ukraine this
year uh there are Ukrainian refugees
who've been given subsidized tickets so
that they can go and enjoy this concert
after an unthinkable year for their
country should there not be a moral line
that unions cannot cross
but look again we just want to make sure
that we do absolutely everything that we
can to avoid uh avoid these going going
ahead and there is still plenty of time
uh to avoid them happening and still
plenty of possibility let's just as I
said these industrial dispute has been
going on for a year let's compare and
contrast that with labor run Wales where
there hasn't been a strike on the rail
operator there on transport for Wales
because the government sat down with
operators and the unions from the
beginning and negotiated in Social
partnership and in good faith these
negotiations are broken down week after
week over the last year because
um that has not been approached in good
faith and the up The Operators the
employers and network rail themselves
have said that the negotiations that are
compromise has been harder to reach
because of the transport secretary the
previous transport secretaries poisonous
rhetoric and because he almost
deliberately undermined the talks in the
prospect of negotiation so look I don't
want this strike to happen on the day of
Eurovision We want to do and I would be
personally doing everything I can to
help bring it about bringing it to a
close but the responsibility rests with
government and it's all well and good
the transport secretary tweeting in
disappointment yesterday but it is his
job to bring everyone to the negotiating
table and avoid it happening in two
weeks time I haven't got my briefing
okay Louise Hague thanks very much I
hope you make it to Eurovision okay it's
been good to have you with us thanks
very much